largas filas de vehículos en esta
gasolinera de sandy springs en el estado
de georgia imágenes que se repitieron
desde texas hasta nueva yersey el
desabastecimiento debido al ciberataque
del pasado viernes contra un oleoducto
de la empresa colonial pipeline
distribuidora del 45% del combustible de
13 estados del este y sur estadounidense
provocó nervios entre algunos ciudadanos
no es muy agradable quieren culparnos
porque creen que es nuestra culpa que no
tengamos gasolina mucha gente es cliente
habitual y son un poco más comprensivos
pero algunos no son muy amables
la compañía anunció el restablecimiento
de sus operaciones después de que el
presidente joe biden hiciera un llamado
a la calma sin embargo el regreso a la
operación normal tomará varios días
extras creo que van a escuchar buenas
noticias en las próximas 24 horas y creo
que todo estará bajo control mientras
tanto facilite el levantamiento de
algunas restricciones sobre el
transporte de combustible así como
acceso a las fuerzas armadas de eeuu que
proporcionan combustible y vehículos
para llevarlo a los lugares donde más se
necesita
berlín se trata de la red más grande de
oleoductos de eeuu por ella pasan
diariamente hasta 25 millones de
barriles de gasolina diésel y
combustible el fbi confirmó que la
infraestructura había sido atacada bajo
la modalidad del ransomware mediante la
cual un programa bloquea el acceso a
información a cambio de una recompensa
en monedas digitales para liberarlo